hi i'm larry hardesty the editor of the
amazon science blog with us today are
two amazon scholars michael jordan and
michael kearns and amazon distinguished
scientist bernhard schulkoff
the amazon scholars program provides a
way for academics to work on large-scale
technical challenges at amazon while
continuing to teach and conduct research
at their universities
professor jordan is the paehong chen
distinguished professor of computer
science at berkeley professor kearns is
a professor of computer scientist
computer science at the university of
pennsylvania and professor shulkoff
directs the empirical inference program
at the max planck institute in tubingen
as most viewers will know nurips the
annual conference on neural information
processing systems is the highest
profile conference in the field of
machine learning
in 2010 nerfs introduced a named lecture
series the posner lecture and in its
first year with the entire universe of
machine learning researchers to choose
from the committee invited michael i
jordan who is to his field with the
other michael jordan's arc theirs to
give the lecture
uh and josh tannenbaum from mit at first
there were two lectures each year
in 2011 with the entire universe of
machine learning researchers to choose
from except michael i jordan and josh
tenenbaum they invited bernhard
schulkoff and michael kearns had to wait
all the way until the fifth year for his
turn the podium
so with this year's nerfs conference
just on the horizon it is a great honor
to be speaking with three researchers
whom the conference is recognized as at
the absolute forefront of their field
so just to get the ball rolling i wanted
to ask in the past decade machine
learning has become its own industry
uh what has that meant for tech for ai
research and for the relationship
between the two
maybe professor jordan you can start
uh yeah actually i'd like to take a
moment to give a little bit of history
of uh
deep learning really back propagation um
i watched david rummelhart who was my
advisor
in the early 1880s
a struggle with trying to get neural
nets to be trained
in those days it had to be very neural
and the heb rule was kind of the
everything your only thing you were
allowed to do
and dave was interested in layered
systems and uh
and realized at some point he needed a
gradient and
figured out he could do a gradient by
going backwards and uh really spent
about a year kind of with little
diagrams and arrows and all that and he
he realized he wasn't being neural at
that point but uh he said well what the
heck and uh and gradients turn out to be
these magical kind of things they just
allow you to move around in high
dimensional spaces and all i think dave
intuited a lot of that and was extremely
excited when he started to to uh get it
to work and uh he got out the minsky and
pappard book
um and started doing all these old
pattern recognition tasks and for you
know including exclusive or the fact
that he could do that with a neural
network was it was a big discovery and
he was extremely excited uh dave sadly
died young and
he would be reaping the benefits and
sort of all the accolades i think at
this point i just wanted to bring his
name up
i also want to say that i think dave had
a broad vision of what he was doing and
he didn't think that pattern recognition
was the end-all he didn't think that
finding maps between one space and
another with supervised labels was the
end-all
and i think he'd be a little alarmed to
see
uh the the the takeover of that
perspective that it's enough you know
you can solve computer vision you can
solve robotics
and all the classical ai problems must
plus you can solve all kinds of other
problems
uh you know climate change or you know
or health
okay or whatever just with mappings from
one space to another based on lots and
lots of labels um and he would not be
surprised that all kinds of problems
start to arise when you deploy those in
the real world
he had a perspective that included
semantics he was for interested in
natural language semantics he was
interested already in causality uh he
was certainly interested in actions and
decisions
and um and the full scope of things he
was a cognitive scientist so he was
interested in understanding mind and
brain and that is one totally valid
perspective
but i also think he had a bit of an
engineering mentality and like to build
things and so on and and personally i
think that's where things have actually
gone it's become much more of an
engineering oriented field um in
industry and elsewhere so i'll stop
there but i just want to return to this
issue a pattern recognition isn't
anything because i think it's a
perspective i want to flesh out
okay
yeah i'll bite as long as we're
reminiscing in the rocking chairs here
on the porch um you know you mentioned
ai and machine learning kind of becoming
a self-contained industry in the last
decade which i i strongly agree with
and you know when i started studying
machine learning in graduate school
at that time machine learning was
you know an obscure subfield of the then
discredited larger field of artificial
intelligence and so certainly if you
told me back then that there would be a
day
when you know
you could pick up the wall street
journal and it would use the words
machine learning as if everybody knew
what they were talking about i would
have you know wouldn't have believed you
i think you know to me the most you know
as as a researcher i think the most
interesting
kind of effects of that change is that
you know now the field is about much
more than the science itself or even the
engineering
so you know
large cloud platform ai and ml providers
um don't just have an army of scientists
engineers and developers they've got
their entire separate own legal
departments public policy groups
analysts relation groups
um and pr as well and and that's quite
interesting and that's fun for me
because
um you know i find myself talking with
people who are in the industry but not
in the science
and so it leads to first of all very
interesting dialogues and it also puts a
premium
on scientists being able to explain
their work
clearly in ordinary language without
kind of losing the important aspects of
it and so that's
something i've been enjoying learning to
do better um in recent years
yeah so that's very interesting to hear
all these things so
i mean you also asked about the
relationship and what does it mean for
tech and
if you think about the big picture
you could say that what we are seeing is
a kind of indus industrialization of
information processing
much like the the
early industrial revolutions were about
industrializing energy processing
and
initially i would say this has probably
started already around the 1950s with
information theory cybernetics etc
early on the information was provided by
humans and now we can automatically
learn it from from data in certain
settings and
and this of course has major
consequences for for all technologies
that rely on information
essentially machine learning allows all
these technologies to scale
and and the scaling then in turn
improves these technologies since it
produces additional data and that's a
that's a virtual virtuous cycle and i
think that's what
a lot of the what drives a lot of the
changes that we're seeing nowadays
um professor jordan you've said recently
that technology should focus on the
complementarity game not the imitation
game
what did you mean by that and how is
that relevant to the i.t industry
um yeah so there's an article that
appeared earlier this week with uh
corrupt colleagues doran also blue and
um and glenn uh that appeared in wired
um maybe to get there i mean
complementarity is a word from an
economist so economists are uh
you know interested in uh trade and
complementarity and uh we get more uh
you know the sum of the parts is more
you know
the holes more than some of the parts
um but just to get there in a couple of
stages first of all i want to talk a
little bit about decision making um
you know because uh you know real world
decision making that's consequential
where there's life and death and and you
know serious consequences isn't just
about thresholding the output of a neuro
neural net and so i like to think of the
example of uh medical diagnosis that uh
you know so imagine you go to your
doctor in a couple of years and the
doctor is in possession of the world's
biggest neural net that's been trained
on all the world's medical data just the
hospitals have all thrown it in there
we've just got everything you possibly
have
and it's really good predictive engine
based on the data it has
there are people in the nurbs community
who sort of say that's everything if we
can predict perfectly we're done um and
i want to argue that's not true
so imagine that the output of one of
those
one of the output units there is you
know a prediction about
heart disease and if the number is over
0.7 based on the historical data it
means you're likely to have a heart
attack and you better do something
um and your number might be 0.701
um you know what are you going to do at
that point are you going to treat that
as a real decision in any sense that a
decision maker has decided something the
answer is definitely not first of all
you're going to ask about the error bars
on that and you don't mean just a little
gaussian error bar you know or some
sampling error bar you mean the
uncertainty and certainly arose for many
reasons maybe the data was gathered a
few years ago not recently maybe the
machine has changed maybe it was
gathered on people different from you uh
different conditions and so you want to
dig into all that and start to you know
help flesh out how uncertain that number
is and it's going to be in the moment
kind of thinking it's not going to be
just an error bar attached to an output
moreover with your doctor you're going
to start to actually have a little
dialogue uh you're going to you're going
to say hey doctor i remember that when i
was a kid i had asthma you know i hadn't
remembered that ever before but now it
becomes relevant in the moment or my
parents had this kind of background or
something and you're going to start to
do counterfactuals you're going to say
you know doctor what if i were to eat
differently or exercise differently or
do this or that how would that change
things
and a good doctor in that moment would
kind of add that as data to the uh to
the to the prediction system and even
train it up a little further and you
know and you know do what if questions
do a b test in the moment
and uh you then you start to develop
trust with the doctor you start to have
a fuller dialogue
all right and and all of those issues of
errors and consequential stuff and uh
um
and uh reasoning really we're talking
about reasoning here at this point
that's what decision making is about all
right
moreover it's never just one decision
i'm making a bunch of decisions today
many of them consequential at different
time scales some of them are lasting
over months period some of them are
today's beer you know and so on
they all are complex web of decisions
that i'm kind of making and it's not
just threshold of the outputs of my
pattern recognition device to do that
based on the historical data it's this
mixture of dialogue and reasoning all
that and then if you think even broader
it's really not just me it's me in the
context of a community and in fact now
it's even a planetary community my
medical care is in fact linked to
michael kearns and to bernard's because
if something happens to them and it
becomes
they become tested on something and it
works then that gets transmitted across
the the medical network
and we're linked by transportation
networks and commerce networks and so on
so forth so all of our decisions
are linked to each other it's not just
the threshold of the outputs of a bunch
of individual pattern recognition
devices
um so i could go on but i hope that kind
of gives a little bit of the spirit of
um
that
it really is just as much about decision
making as is about pattern recognition
and decision making is never just based
on historical data and trying to you
know fit a network to that of some kind
and make a prediction it's always about
using that in a flexible way in that
moment and new things become relevant in
the moment that weren't actually in the
historical data at all
and that's something that you know is
critical to real decision making and
then this last one i'll stop and maybe
return to it because i do want to talk
about the economic side which is that uh
you know if if uh if i make a decision
and michael makes a decision and there's
a scarcity in the real world both of us
can't have what we want um then that's
got to be accounted for um
and uh in the in the learning system and
kind of there needs to be auctions and
bids and valuations and and economic
ideas brought to bear
okay
um so uh professor kearns that the the
idea that uh the real world consequences
are not just a matter of the output of a
neural net and i think that dovetails
with some interest of yours in uh
privacy and
the ethics of machine learning
yeah i mean um
again kind of just
looking back not too too far in history
right i mean there was a period not long
ago where machine learning
you know the field machine learning
basically
um
was
was left alone by the world and it left
the world alone so what i mean by that
is
you know
earlier in my career right the you know
most examples of
machine learning in the field or an
industry
were really not about making predictions
or decisions about individual people it
was more about systems so you might try
you know like a very old example is you
know using historical data to build
models to try to predict directional
movement in the stock market for example
so this has been going on in finance and
wall street for
many decades
and you know so so in something like
that you know you're they're trying to
predict the
the movements or behavior of a system
and it might involve you know individual
people making trading decisions but
you're not really trying to make
predictions at that sort of granular
level and so machine learning was sort
of operating not on people but on
systems
um and so you know we weren't really
impinging on individuals and the world
kind of didn't care about us either
and now of course especially you know
because of advances in machine learning
itself and also just like the
rise of availability of individual level
data because of the consumer internet
you know we're in a very very different
place now where we do build models and
systems that make consequential
predictions and decisions about
individual people from their historical
data
and you know obviously
i'm sure everybody in the audience
knows that with this has come
a lot of ethical concerns and
demonstrations of sort of unintended
negative social side effects of machine
learning like discriminatory models
or you know privacy violations or the
like
um and as you know i've talked about
extensively elsewhere there's an entire
science
of addressing these problems that's you
know still under very early development
but it's quite interesting
i i think you know the other places
where this intersects the outside world
is on things like the regulatory front
right so i think it's becoming very
clear that you know whatever one's
opinion about it is
machine learning is going to face
regulatory scrutiny i mean it already is
and i think that that's a very
interesting frontier because you know
when you look at current regulatory
proposals around ai and machine learning
they're they're well intentioned and
many of them are broadly sensible
but they're um you know to somebody like
me
they're sort of vastly underspecified
and
therefore you know in my view probably
unenforceable
um and so you know one like slightly
controversial opinion is that i really
think algorithmic regulation needs to
look much more algorithmic itself
because at the end of the day we are you
know we are essentially building
artifacts that are out in the world
making decisions and will make decisions
or predictions on any input you give
them that's the whole point of
algorithms and machine learning is that
you know you don't have to explicitly
specify what you're going to do in every
single corner case but the model will do
something in every in every corner case
and until we get regulation that kind of
you know
really is more in the language of
algorithms itself i think the gap
between you know well-intentioned
regulations and actual enforceability
will remain very very wide
and
i'll admit that i don't know how we'll
close that gap i mean i think it's both
it's like hard to do even if you had the
people on hand to do it um but i think
the real problem is is just the number
of people with the trade the training
needed at that intersection of kind of
legal and regulatory expertise and
enough technical knowledge about how
things work is so small right now
that um you know the whole the whole
problem is basically understaffed
right
uh another aspect of the uh real world
consequences of uh you know the outputs
of neural networks is that there's an
assumption that um the real world looks
like the data that the neural network is
trained on and professor shulkoff i
think that's kind of a concern of yours
right
yeah yeah so for me this relates to
the mechanism that have generated
statistical dependencies in the first
place so it gets closer to physics and
to causality because machine learning
ultimately is based on statistical
dependencies
and we usually don't ask where they
actually come from but
ultimately statistical dependencies come
from couple time evolutions in physical
systems and maybe that's too extreme we
don't want to start modeling everything
in terms of couple differential
equations but then there's this
intermediate level and one of the first
people to to understand that was the the
philosopher hans reichenbach
who wrote this book called the the the
direction of time
and he postulated that uh every
statistical dependence has a causal
explanation uh so if two quantities are
statistically independent it means
either one of them causes the other one
or there's there's something else that
has caused both of them
and so so in that sense causality is a a
concept that
describes the dependencies in a system
on a more fundamental level that
produces statistical dependencies on on
the surface but
and and oftentimes it's enough if we
work at that surface and just learn from
these dependencies
but basically it turns out that
it's only enough as long as we're in
this setting where nothing changes once
things start changing it's actually
helpful
to think about the causality and
so this is uh i mean i got interested in
causality 10 or 15 years ago
when there wasn't much interest in the
machine in the community for that
initially i also didn't connect it much
to machine i think i just thought it's a
it's a very interesting problem
but at some point uh
we started noticing that it is connected
so for instance if you have that there's
this old example from the neural network
literature it's probably it's probably
just an urban myth that someone was
training a neural network to recognize
uh tanks and distinguish i don't know
russian from american tanks and
they noticed it worked with a hundred
percent accuracy
and then when they tried to deploy it it
didn't work anymore and uh and of course
the the reason was something like the
american tanks where we're all
photographed on a sunny day in the
russian tanks on a cloudy day so the
neural network was just looking at the
color of the background so something
like this in these kind of examples
they're amusing but
funny thing we are we haven't made all
that much progress these things still
happen if we just blindly train our
neural networks
because in practice we usually can't
guarantee that nothing has changed then
we we often fall for these kind of
pitfalls and then we have to start
thinking uh modeling more explicitly
these issues such as data shift data set
shift etcetera right
this is related to causality and to
understanding the mechanisms that
generate the dependencies and so that's
leads in this direction of causal
learning
right right can i can i jump in a little
bit there um just to kind of help
tie together the last
sequence of comments um i think bernard
would probably willing to agree that
it's not just physical causes it's a
social as well um
you know depending on how you want to
define social um you know it
um yeah and and so um you know one of
the feedback loops that's definitely uh
appears when you start to really work in
the real world and collect data and all
that is that people care about the
outcome and so you get into what
economists call good hearts law which is
that if you start to measure something
and people are aware it's being measured
and they want to optimize that thing
they will change their data so as to
arrive at a better outcome so you know
if you're doing credit scoring and
people are aware you're using a certain
model they'll learn about how the model
works and they'll shift their data to
get a better outcome um and that just
doesn't happen a little bit that happens
all the time and so you know there is a
dependency now um and the dependency is
coming because there's a social agent
who's still self-interested and and is
eager to change that outcome
um and you you can't just sort of say
wish that away that that's really part
of it and so an economist would say well
that's a game there's a game theoretic
situation going on here
and there must be costs and benefits and
there must be an equilibrium um so it
you know what we want to measure then is
is something some things that are stable
about the world um if we don't measure
unstable things that people can just
change their vector arbitrarily then
there's the game is not very interesting
but if we measure things that are stable
at the world it makes it kind of hard to
change so i can't change my height very
easily maybe i could work really hard or
i could maybe change my health a little
bit but i have to work hard at it and um
so i can put those costs and benefits
into the to the vector if those become
important but now i will i will do that
and i will move my x vector a little bit
at least um and now you as the central
modeler should be aware of that and you
should be aware that the data has
probably been moved a little bit
and the model should take that into
account and there should be something so
this is a game theoretic issue this is a
so these are called stackleberg
equilibria uh and there's a whole huge
literature on these um but these are new
kinds of equilibrium first they're in
high dimensional spaces uh secondly
they're based on data analysis they're
not based on just writing down a game
and analyzing its dynamics a man there's
a causal story and of course there's a
fairness story because really it's all
about do i get an outcome that's fair to
everybody
given that everybody wants a certain
outcome you know what what is the right
way to think about it um you know so um
let me again stop there but just to say
that uh to me at least it helps very
very much to put the economics together
with the social together with the causal
and all of that and the decision making
around it if you start to think at that
level you put the pieces all together
and you start to think about how would i
design a
system that actually does effectively
work that doesn't fall into these stupid
little traps
that actually reflects people's social
welfare and actually scalable and it's
going to work in a long time
and they're just the broader you know
question about what am i designing here
i'm really designing it some kind of a
market
i'm not designing just a machine
learning system a box all right i'm
designing some kind of a market where
there are valuations and there's
long-term behavior
and markets have their troubles and all
that but but the dynamics of markets are
stuck so they can often persist for
decades or even centuries fairly
effectively adapting to conditions
adapting to situations having a
robustness and all that and until we
start to bring that style of thinking
into our system's view of neural
networks our systems are not going to be
robust they're not going to work over
lime time scales in fact our networks
don't work over like a day
to think of a network that will work
over a month or years it's just it's
just completely and so we need to start
to bring in that style of thinking of
equilibria and not just optima and
social agents and collecting data and
and when you do that i mean causal is
definitely part of it because it is the
stable underlying thing you're trying to
get at to make any of this possible
yeah i mean on the on the
topic of connections between sort of
econ game theory and fairness which is
an interesting topic
um you know one framework that's emerged
in recent years for
essentially enforcing fairness
constraints in the training of the model
is very explicitly game theoretic
in which you basically you know design
your algorithm in a way
that sets it up as a two-player game
where one of the player is sort of a
learner of the traditional variety who
generally is just concerned with
predictive accuracy
and the other player you can think of as
a regulator who is there to enforce the
fairness constraints and there's
technical work on this that exactly kind
of captures what mike said about kind of
the sort of solution to this constrained
optimization problem being the formal
equilibrium of a game
one thing that's interesting about that
approach though is you could even
imagine
kind of ripping the regulator out of the
code itself and actually having it be a
literal regulator so the these kind of
same
framework for algorithm design could be
thought of as a crude model for
what might actually be the real world
back and forth between let's say a tech
regulator whose goal is to enforce kind
of anti-discrimination laws in
predictive models and the regulates
um i wanted to just come back to
something that bernard said about
causality i have a
complicated relationship with causality
and i've i've never really done any
serious work in it it's a fascinating
topic
i admire people who work in it because
it's extremely hard
what's the cause of that michael what's
the cause of your
connection to causality just too much
other stuff to do but but i mean i'm not
they never say never
just have never kind of found the right
set of problems to think about
but but one
the comment that bernard made about this
example of you know the tanks and sunny
days versus cloudy days
um
you know an even more interesting
version of that to me is the possibility
that we might build predictive models
that are extremely accurate let's say
matching human accuracy
um on some cognitive tasks that you know
we're good at
um
and it might not be that you know in
that tank example right you know
like something bad has happened right
the model has learned the wrong thing it
didn't really solve the problem that we
intended
but it could be that you know we're
building predictive models especially in
the year of deep learning that basically
are extremely accurate
not for sort of spurious reasons but
they they just do it in a way they found
a different solution to the problem than
we we have right there's there's in in
particular right like you know the
famous example is aviation right so for
i don't know i'm you know know little
about the history but for some long
prefix of artificial aviation
people would look at birds and think
like okay we should design
flying machines that actually have you
know flapping wings and then at some
point you know it's figured out no
there's an actually completely different
way
of flying than the way you know nature
does it
and um you know i think this kind of um
this kind of thing is relevant to
discussions around things like
explainability in machine learning right
now where you know there's a sense in
which i worry that in the explainability
literature where we're
anthropomorphizing and sort of expecting
explanations from let's say a deep
neural network
that um kind of are projected on to the
same way we solve a problem so the
example would be you know like
the all-important problem of detecting
cats and images
right it could be that we built a neural
network that's fantastic at predicting
cats and images but it's just doing it
in a completely different way than than
we do it you know maybe there's some
reflective property of cats per that we
can't even detect
but um you know is an important feature
for the neural network
and so if you if you
take something like that and then you
say like okay i want an explanation out
of it that matches our intuitions about
what makes a cat image a cat like you
know a couple of pointy ears around an
oval with you know a little pink
triangle in the middle and a little grid
of whiskers it's just going to be total
failure and so i do think that in areas
like you know
fairness and explainability
kind of causal
you know causal mechanisms might be
important there right especially so
michael what about
certain
ways of solving the problem
surely there are problems that are like
if if you deny me it alone at the bank
and i demand an explanation um you're
gonna have to give me one right and and
uh the government's probably gonna make
you give me one and if you use the
neural net inside the box you're gonna
have to do something about that
here's the simple answer that i like to
think about which is just that in
parallel the you're going to also build
a a um a nearest neighbor machine
um and take 50 nearest neighbors um
and it's the you know probably it you
know nearest neighbors is just going to
smooth the surface locally around the
query point just like a neural net i bet
we could do in terms of predictive
accuracy we could have a parallel system
that's just about as accurate and why do
people not use
nearest neighbor because it's extremely
slow at lookup time right and it's very
hard to you know it can't be you know a
fast commodity um but if your regulator
is coming in and saying well here's what
the person is asking they didn't get a
loan and they want to know why and you
show them 50 people that are in the you
know the neighborhood maybe defined by
the contours of the neural net uh here's
50 people and here's their label some of
them got the loan some of them did and
you look at those 50 people say oh i see
that person got it because they did this
differently me
and all that um that that's not trying
to solve necessarily technical problems
trying to solve the user interface to
humans and humans are very much
case-based reasoners we like to think
about this and so part of our reasoning
would be coming in as causal but you
know trying to to solve the
hard hard problem of looking in a neural
network box and then thinking about you
know finding its causes and turning over
to people that seems hard to me but
whereas showing them a few examples
seems um seems more practical
i think for humans explanations
are often expected to be causal
and i think one can speculate why this
is the case i think one of the reasons
might be that those are those tend to be
the more robust explanations and this
relates also to how humans learn because
we don't just learn from input output
examples
there's a lot of uh cultural learning
going on we learn from things that
people have learned previously and where
we have developed efficient means of
passing on that knowledge that doesn't
involve input output examples
so i think for us explanations are often
causal but but then there are some other
cases like if you think of a
self-driving car or a car driven by an
intelligent system and that system could
be a human or could be a machine
and and maybe we we want to be able to
scrutinize this system if something goes
wrong if there's an accident
now i think this the level of
explanation that we expect of such a
system
will necessarily scale with the
complexity of the task and the
complexity of the system so if a truck
driver makes an accident or causes an
accident
we we're not going to start analyzing
the neurons in the brain but we might
ask whether the driver was writing a
text message on the cell phone or
whether they were drunk so that we have
certain modes of of
interrogating such a system and and
explaining it to some extent and then i
think once we've exhausted those notes
then maybe we are we are happy
afterwards
and eventually i think for complex
technical systems that solve similarly
complex problems
we might have to make do with
equally sort of somewhat limited modes
of explanation also
yeah be not to
beat up on the field of explainability
too much because it's very early days i
mean the theoretician
in me which is not a small part um
basically feels like the real problem is
we don't have any good definitions so if
you look at you know if you look at the
fairness literature the problem there is
we have too many definitions but you
know for the most part many of them are
sensible
um
you know if you
if you ask
in many ways like
in explainability and interpretability
what we have right now are simply
proposals of things to try right you
know you you you could do something like
what mike said and maybe people would
find out a satisfying explanation you
have other things you know that
essentially try to measure the influence
each particular input has over the
output
but but nobody can answer the question
like well
for what definition of explainability is
that the right answer is that a good
algorithm right so it's just like that
that part of it's a black hole
and
you know being someone who believes that
at least good foundational research has
to start with good definitions that that
seems to me something that's
badly missing right now um and i've
spent you know like
enough time thinking about it to realize
that it's hard my good friend and
colleague aaron roth has made the quip
that you know it's a bad sign for a
field when the best research going on in
it is debunking the current proposals um
and and there's a sense in which that
that's somewhat the state of
explainability research
certainly though there are going to be
problems also just to turn the flip the
coin back the other way there are
problems where you don't need an
explanation right um i mean if i ask
michael how you do the high jump
and you're really good at the high jump
you know you're not going to be able to
explain it to me in terms of the muscles
that you use and all that i mean maybe
with great effort um
and and maybe you'll discover the foster
flop and you'll have done it a
completely different way and so on so um
you know the writer
yeah
you know there's definitely aspects of
mappings from an input output which is
there's no way that any of us could
explain and more of those will happen in
real life as these things yeah they
absolutely rolling out but i think the
legal professions as you alluded to
earlier michael is going to have to come
in
um and in domains where it actually is
consequential and uh you know think
about the entire you know loan process
and you know just like conference
reviewing process needs a lot of thought
right there's kind of a
fairness issues coming in there's
explaining issues and all that and it's
where people are starting to interact
with decisions but with automatics that
we're yeah we're definitely lagging and
definitely it's going to be a few
decades but it's not going to be just a
technical solution it's obviously a
part of the social and legal texture of
our times
agreed
okay we've all raised a bunch of pretty
fascinating issues and difficult
problems and i guess i just wanted to
ask you kind of what what path forward
do you see from here
i want to return to a couple of things
that just only got hinted at a little
bit um you know one of them i'm writing
a long op-ed uh with some of these
social science colleagues that i
mentioned earlier um
and one of the things that we do kind of
uh want to raise is the issue of
autonomy um so there's two buzzwords of
our time which have you know really
caught people's attention one is
intelligence that we're somehow
discovering what intelligence is
and i personally don't think that's what
we're doing we don't have you know we
have even less definitions of
intelligence than we have of
explainability um we are trying to
develop intelligent systems whatever
that means and i don't think it's like
replacing a human with a computer it's
it's building systems that behave in
predictable useful so-and-so ways
um the other buzzword which i have even
more trouble with is autonomy
it's viewed as a desirable feature that
i got an autonomous system and we often
say autonomous self-driving cars and
there's whole little kind of workshops
on autonomy
um and and i think we need to question a
little bit about why autonomy
um you know and so i because i think
part of the problem is that it goes back
to the old ai uh dream which is that i'm
gonna you know have my touring machine
who can't communicate with anybody and
it's gonna
you know answer the touring questions or
i'm gonna have my robot that i'm gonna
push out on the stage and it's going to
dance and sing and talk in natural
language and i'm not there's no chord
attached to it right so it's a show-off
kind of thing that i could make my
systems autonomous
uh and it's a show it's a thing that
implies that i've somehow discovered
like you know frankenstein that's the
secret elixir of of life and
intelligence that i can you know so i
stand back and and look at my proud
creation
um
now now now most systems that i want to
build i don't want autonomy so
self-driving cars i do not want
autonomous self-driving cars just like i
don't want autonomous self-flying planes
i want them federated and talking to
each other and uh sending high-level
information back and forth and making
plans together and having a network
that's all federated up and have uh
interfaces and and engineering thought
given to building that entire system and
in fact it's not just a car it's a whole
transportation system that gets people
and packages around the world
that should be thought of at that level
if it's not it's just not the right
so really we're building like a like a
you know a system that brings food into
a city we're bringing the entire system
we're not just you know bringing one
piece of bread into the city
autonomously whatever that might mean
um you know moreover i think that so
autonomy is just often just the wrong
level of analysis um
and then often i think it tends to
concentrate power in the hands of too
few you know so that you know the number
of people who've developed say you know
gt3 or something is a small handful of
humanity
right um and and it's sort of being held
you know closely and it's and and
companies have to if they're going to
show that they've done it autonomously
they can't have thousands of people
working on it that that
meant too much human intelligence went
into it we didn't solve an ai problem a
small team means we solved an ai problem
so wikipedia is not an ai you know
entity right even though it's super
intelligent it's more intelligent than
any other ai artifact i can think of uh
but it's not an ai artifact because all
these humans put all this effort into it
right um it's not an autonomous system
wikipedia um but it's the most effective
thing we have right in terms of the
semantics uh on the computer um you know
so uh uh autonomy then tends to conserve
power in the hands of the other few and
and we are some of the elite here uh you
know but we really have to recognize
that that's a problem that we don't want
to have these these artifacts this
technical power concentrated in the
hands of a few
locked away and then you know they
didn't they did it for good reasons they
were trying to help humanity but
nonetheless they got a huge power
leverage that that other people don't
have
um and it's really it's not that they
have super knowledge or anything they
just had the you know the the data and
the time and the wherewithal to do all
that
and you can pull away from that if you
can say the goal is not to develop these
autonomous ai type things the goal is to
federate the goal is to build
complementary systems that interact with
each other interact well with humans uh
trade is possible etc open it all up and
let things flow and then design the
level of systems and systems should be
planetary scale
you know it shouldn't be just your
little company and your little you know
hci kind of interface to a human being
it should be the entire federated system
um so again let me stop there to just i
wanted to kind of open this up you know
to me part of the way forward here as a
technical minded person is to indeed
bring in economics and social science
concepts they're sort of sitting there
ready to be brought together with
statistical machine learning
most economics work doesn't have a lot
of statistics in it there's econometrics
where you measure the economy but the
mechanism design and the thinking about
agents and all that is you assume the
preferences or distributions are known
well we don't assume those kind of
things so it's just a natural marriage
and we can start to think at the systems
level
um so anyway i really intelligence ai
i've kind of you know in a lot of my
writings i've kind of you know
hankered for a different terminology i
think it's sad that we're going back to
the 50s term you know vision which we
don't have the same vision
um but anyway i've kind of relented on
that but autonomy i just really want to
question more deeply i think it's it's
it's really misleading
uh
it's misleading us as researchers into
goals that we actually don't really
aspire to
i mean i would tend to think also in
humans you don't want full autonomy if a
human drives a car you also want them to
sort of interact with other cars and not
just go full power through every
crossing so there's always going to be
some limitations to
personal autonomy if you want the
overall system to work so i think i
i share your view
and if i now come
maybe give a slightly different answer
to the to the question
about where to go or where
where we see sort of promising paths in
the future so i i think i share your
overall vision mike i think this is
the right way to think of the broad
picture
at the same time i think it's it's very
complex
if you have the complexity of economics
multiplayer games causality etc you put
it all together
you have to break it apart somehow and
for me personally the next step or next
thing that i want to understand is
probably something simpler
but already pretty hard i find
for me that's the field of causal
representation learning
and by that i mean so if we go back to
the classical ai at the beginning
uh we were people were assuming that the
symbols are given think of a chess
program we know what are the chess
pieces what other possible moves
and people were assuming that
also the programs how to generate
intelligence based on these by
processing these symbols are provided by
humans so both is provided and let's see
how far we get
and that didn't take us very far then
machine learning came around
and so with machine learning so that the
advancing machine was not just that the
rules are learned but also at least uh
with most of modern machine learning
that also that the representations and
the symbols are automatically learned
now if we as i've argued before we have
to move towards when to move towards
causal learning and not just everything
based on statistical dependencies only
then uh if we look at most methods in
causality in a certain sense we are
going back to the symbolic stage because
they are usually pretty low dimensional
and we have someone gives us the symbols
and now we want to learn what are the
causal relationships and how do we
correct for confounding etc
so in a way we've
even if we can combine it with machine
learning it looks like we've taken a
step back so i think what we need in
that direction is we have to develop
this field of causal representation
learning so we want to learn both the
connections the mechanisms that connect
variables and also what are the
variables in the first place how do you
identify the useful variables in high
dimensional data so i think that's
going to be interesting because current
representation learning is really mostly
about just learning statistical
representations which are useful for
prediction but
maybe not much more and
ultimately i like this quotation of
convert logan's the austrian ethologist
he once said that thinking is nothing
but acting in the imagined space
so if we want to have representations or
imagine spaces in which we can also
think or act
then these spaces have to contain
notions of intervention so i think these
kind of causal representations they will
also go towards what i think mike
referred to before towards reasoning
which we will ultimately need if we want
to move away from this pure pattern
recognition view of intelligence
i get the last word i guess
sure um
you know i've never
i've never been a researcher to have a
five or ten year plan myself and
have mild suspicion of those who do
so the idea of my you know pontificating
about the next 10 years of our field and
industry is is obviously even harder
but i i will tell you the the area that
i'm
most interested in watching play out
because i think
like big big things will have to happen
there and and it will you know
be a strong influence on our field it is
the regulatory and legal landscape and i
think that you know
um this isn't just a matter of you know
waiting around for the ftc to decide
what it's going to do or what it's not
going to do i really think there needs
to be some sort of
bottom-up fundamental
reframing of the of sort of technology
regulation and how it interacts with
technologies like iai and machine
learning and also kind of a whole scale
change in the way we train scientists
the way we train engineers the way we
train
attorneys regulators and the like so i
think that that you know
that's going to be a very very
interesting important
area that has to somehow get populated
over the next decade um and so that
that's the area i think i want to keep a
close eye on
is that something that stands outside
machine learning or is that kind of
regulation part of this huge no that's
kind of you know as per my earlier
remarks i i don't think it can be i
don't think it can be like i i do not
think it's a good idea for people who
don't have sufficient understanding of
the science itself
to be regulating it and i also don't
think it's a good idea
for you know the science to be entirely
unregulated right we can kind of see
that there have been you know
major
side effects of that
um and so i think
this this has to be a partnership
somehow i think it's very far from that
right now but there sort of seems to be
general agreement in the room that
something has to change on both sides
and so i think
that that's
that should be interesting to watch
okay so i'd like to note that um
historically there have been examples of
this and i'm not sure the word science
is actually quite right here because
like chemical engineering or electrical
engineering
right when they came on the scene they
were building on science
in both cases
you know chemistry and electrons and so
on
but they built systems that work for
humans at scale and they had to be
regulated so you would not bring
electricity to your home unless the
underwriters laboratory had kind of you
know signed off and when and the whole
system was regulated in ways that it
wasn't going to damage humans and and so
on so the whole field of chemical
engineering
was a bringing together of basic
scientific concepts with scalability
concerns with regulatory concerns and a
whole new ecosystem developed to make it
possible to have chemicals you know
flying around our world in new ways and
new configurations and similarly with
electrical engineering i personally
actually think that's what's happening
now this is information
science engineering whatever you want to
call it there's not a good terminology
for it but it's the engineering of
flows of data flows of values
flows of decisions interacting with
humans and computing
to build systems that hopefully you know
entertain us make our life safer make
our lives more enriched and so on and
those systems have to be regulated uh if
they're not it's just there's just it's
we shouldn't be doing it but it is a
large-scale engineering system and
problem it's not just the math meets the
lawyers it's it's about the whole
engineering style thinking and michael i
think is totally right about
not just bringing all those together but
also a new way of training to have the
engine the emerging information
engineers or whatever you want to call
them
to be able to simultaneously think of
the regulatory environment that they're
building the systems they're building
and the the fundamental principles
okay
um i'll just one last comment which is
that uh you know we're not really
focusing too much on industry here you
know this is an idea thought leader kind
of forum uh just to say that this style
thinking i see more in industry than i
see in academia
you know in industry you solve a problem
and you bring in people from all these
different points of view and you think
through the problem and the consequences
a little bit because if you build a
product that doesn't you know that fails
in one of these dimensions it's not
gonna work and so you do see more of
this dialogue there and uh i think
that's another kind of way to go is to
get our industry academic connections to
fire up some of these challenges and
to help you know
push each other on both sides
great
well you're all three illustrations of
the way amazon is trying to do that to
foster that connection with academia
all right
well uh thank you very much this has
been hugely enlightening uh and uh
yeah i i look forward to see what
happens on on all these fronts in the
future
thank you thank you thank you
you